Does the safe sleeve work the same way the heatron does or e-MF protection?
No, so the heatron can help
the e-MFs that are coming off your phone to be less damaging to you. The safe sleeve locks e-MFs.
So two different things there. So you could use both a heatron. I have a heatron on my phone and I use a safe sleeve.
And I almost never put my phone up to my ear to talk. I use my phone almost always either in the car, the speaker or a speaker phone.
Not putting it up to my ear. So you want to keep the e-MFs away from you as much as possible. The safe sleeve blocks the e-MFs.
So with the safe sleeve, you can close the front face of it and still talk on the phone up to your ear. It's going to block a good degree of e-MFs.
And that if you want to completely block the e-MFs from your phone, you can put it in what's called a fair-to-cage. Fair-to-cage is a term that means that you're putting it in some
type of sleeve or compartment that blocks all e-MFs, blocks all frequencies.
You will be able to receive phone calls or text notes in that. So we have those. They're super cheap. I think they're $15. They're the fabric, double fabric.
Sleeves that are a little bit bigger than your phone, that you can slip your phone into and you're basically putting your phone to sleep. So you're not going to be able to receive phone calls and you're not going to be able to receive text, but you will deduct it hitting e-MFs from it.
So there's benefits to doing that at different times, like when you can still put the charging cord outside the phone. You don't have to close up the sleeve and you can charge your phone at night.
Without getting any e-MFs, close better to keep it going away from it.